Ladies and gentlemen, our takeover of General Motors is complete.
Dr. Evil, we can now use GM's Ultium platform to power our whole operation.
Now we can reduce tailpipe emissions.
I'm sorry, am I no longer Dr. Evil, I'm Dr. Good now?
I didn't get the memo.
Climate change is arguably the number one threat to the world now.
Dr. Evil, you are the number two threat to the world.
I refuse to be number two, Number 2.
We have to help the planet.
Oh please. Tear...
For my son.
Your son?
I shall name him Baby Me.
No, his name is Kyle.
You must help save the world first...
...then you can take over the world.
Okay, Frau, how about you let me do the business, alright?
Hold on, I've got it.
I will help save the world first then take over the world.
She literally just said that.
Scott, you just don't get it, do you?
What?
What don't I get?
You don't get it.
And you're never gonna get it.
You can't draw me into these little...
You act like a child.
Here it is... you don't get it.
I am an adult!
You can't push my buttons anymore!
Stop!
We'll reduce our carbon footprint.
Whatever.
Okay, let's go!
We're going all electric!
Everybody in!
Not you, Scott.
One day, you're going to run the company, Baby Me.